[Musique]
je suis convaincu de la capacité des
électeurs aient l'air de choisir un
candidat qui soit acceptable pour une
grande majorité des français et je pense
que
voilà si on veut avoir une chance de
gagner il vaut mieux trek pécresse
bertrand ou barnier qu'avec ceux qui
seront à départager au deuxième tour qui
va s'ouvrir dès demain matin à 8 heures
eric ciotti et valérie pécresse voilà
pour les résultats et moore qui a
félicité
eric ciotti on va découvrir le tweet
heureux cher eric de voir nos idées si
largement partagé par les militants et
l'air au terme d'une élection très
serrée sur les cinq candidats quatre ont
dépassé les 22 % avec en tête une
surprise eric ciotti député des alpes
maritimes
défenseur d'une grotte dieu avec les
parlementaires qui sont ici que je salue
sans bras boel valérie bazin mal grâce
stéphane ravier jeu julien rabier
stéphane ravier jeu c'est julien rabier
et oui parce que stéphane ravier cet art
sénateurs rassemblement national je ne
regrette vraiment pas vraiment pas
d'avoir présenté ma candidature à ce
congrès ce sont les adhérents qui ont
tranché sont eux qui ont décidé c'est la
démocratie
c'est 113000 vote sont une terrible
dérouillée pour tous ceux qui
prétendaient que la droite était divisée
et à terre du côté de l'elysée ils vont
devoir réécrire leur scénario et je
souhaite faire campagne pour ce second
tour et qu'elle puisse emporter je parle
de valérie pécresse nous gagnerons unis
nous gouvernerons unis à papier sur vous
qui s'appelait gaspard proust eric
zemmour de l'humour les profs les juifs
et chiennes de garde hélas on cherche en
vain le second degré oui c'était c'était
c'était un article c'est vrai 2011 déjà
d'envoi qu'elle a pas vu le deuxième
spectacle parce que qu'est-ce que leurs
écrits à ce moment là une île un quart
d'heure plus tôt tout ce que je déteste
dans la vie politique d'abord ça
sa candidature relève quasiment de la
psychiatrie se plaint aujourd'hui
quelques heures après avoir annoncé sa
candidature qu'on le ramène à ses
provocations et à ses propos choquants
mais bienvenu en politique coop après
c'est vrai qu'il fait beaucoup pour plus
polis populariser la septième symphonie
de
beethoven dont tout le monde sait ce que
c'est vrai c'est une très belle oeuvre
donc c'est pas forcément ce que j'aurai
choisi par du noir d'heure c'est
apocalyptique faire tu as juste envie
pour voter pour quelqu'un te dire il
représente l'année soir là la mise en
scène un peu pastiche du de charles de
gaulle à fille d'une ancienne ministre
de lionel jospin aurait été la victime
de nicolas hulot whissell jeune femme
s'est retrouvée un soir dans
l'appartement de nicolas hulot et ce
dernier aurait littéralement tenté de
lui sauter dessus c'est une histoire qui
est connu depuis des années encore une
fois dans tout le milieu écolo et aussi
de chez beaucoup de deux journalistes
notamment à paris et je pense que ce qui
est important c'est de comprendre qu'il
s'agit d'une vraie omerta sur paris
match j'ai envie de dire tout le monde
savait y compris paris match paris-match
en 2019 c'est une ultra complaisante un
dossier d'une dizaine de pages limite
publi reportages pour nicolas hulot
alors où ces nouvelles accusations de
violence sexuelle 20 vise jean vincent
placé une collaboratrice de l'ex
secrétaire d'état écologiste l'accusant
une plainte de harcèlement sexuel entre
le 2012 et 2016 du profil du porteur du
variant au micro on ne sait que très peu
de choses c'est un homme entre 50 et 60
ans il n'a pas de symptômes et est
arrivé le 25 novembre sur le territoire
en provenance du nigeria on est inquiet
bien évidemment si on passe de 58 à 60
milles 70 milles contamination france
entière on va voir effectivement se
retrouver dans des situations qui
peuvent être comparable aux vagues
précédentes et notamment la première et
la troisième qui ont été les pires noël
n'est pas en danger
si nous faisons tous attention